it's a fool a Capcom exclusive you
mentioned your visuals um the imagery
and like your your videos dog remind me
alike like I want to say just early like
nine just the phrase blades in the mouth
and you know just the imagery is [__]
crazy and your music videos how much of
that is you like in your vision or is
that you know more more credit to the
director hell no hell no let me get this
straight right now
directors don't come up with none of my
treatments not to say that they not
talented or they write they don't have
to maybe they can't do it I just I'm a
very hands-on type of person me and Ola
who's an eggroll Cree that's my little
brother know permeated the whole temple
[__] we both come together and we create
all our treatments five videos every
Studios a crazy
thank you brother but it's all that's me
you know saying everything that you see
with the razor blades in my mouth I put
razor blades my mom because that's the
Puerto Rican Dominican thing when you go
to New York when you went Rikers Island
that's naughty high blades and a month
they used to I'm saying there was a time
in the 90s that it was the court used to
call on Rikers Island Easter when you
used to fight you scored Ray's attack
and I'm saying so the only rapper I
remember who would do that with math
used to have oh yeah yeah exactly
me saying so so Dom I mean and you bring
up the fact that you know his real 98
I'm like I grew up on 90s music and
that's my love from 98 to 2000 2001 no
with the exception of 50 like that was
the year where I was really introduced
and I fell in love with hip-hop and I'm
saying so it's a very very big influence
of what I do you know so I had to bring
that back out you know i mean the whole
razor place is really keeping in New
York I'm saying cuz that's where I'm
from that's where I rest my head that's
what's up man so next year wait - - and
what is that what is the name of the
present well next year did not believe
me you're gonna take over the whole mall
[__] world I'm saying that's that's
the gold man early 2014
hopefully yeah hopefully I'm definitely
who do you want to work with man like
you have you know you you've got some
collabs you know within the circle
who somebody who you want to get with it
maybe Mike might catch someone our
lawyer might be out of your comfort zone
like how many wives oh I definitely want
to work with Blackrock oh yeah I feel
like not a Spanish on his album was so
honest
no wonder 88 definitely so under that
black robbers an artist is very on the
red black robbers wore the best ever
like just a story something his first
album was crazy yeah yeah definitely
story was amazing a black rock beat him
saying um definitely you know I mean
like I would love to work with home as
producers wise now we're not there
working [__] 400 [__] [__]
that you know change music I want where
people will change [__] music who
changed the whole landscape Kanye or
something yeah like I would love outside
the box you as where doesn't sound like
to work with more [__] what like in I
love what I am [__] yo will.i.am is
hip-hop [__] when he's on his hip-hop
she's amazing like Gaines Compton love
love Oh crazy crazy so well I guess he
just comes off like an [__] but he
when he gets on his hip-hop [__] well I
am is he so incredible I definitely yeah
you need to do more that I definitely
want to UM Salaam Remi you saying like a
lot of the older cats really mounted
this [__] game I had the chance
you know to get a beef from alchemists
that was amazing I'm saying this is one
of the greatest ever and one of the most
underrated ever you I'm saying so you
know just give a primo oh I met primo
once I'm definitely some City yeah yeah
definitely some [__] you got to get what
primo [__] man I appreciate your
time my dude you already know bodega
Bam's 1000 you were